warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised yeah over 80
percent of people who identify with the
lgbtq plus Community have been sexually
assaulted in their past
um often childhood I myself started to
battle with with feelings of Attraction
towards women
I don't know if you've ever been
severely depressed maybe you've suffered
abuse it is an awful thing to go through
but today's conversation is is going to
be a hard one it's an important
conversation and we need to have this
conversation and I I think that we can't
talk about these issues enough because I
guarantee more people suffer from these
things than we give credit to so
welcome Marriott to LED live
um glad to have you on our show thank
you so much Scotty I'm glad to be here
and I'm glad that you're willing to come
on and be honest and talk about some of
these things that that you've had to go
through in life
but the reason we want to talk about
this is there is hope there's hope that
the light at the end of the tunnel
that's right and that's what you're
going to hear today so Mary Ellen tell
us a little bit about uh growing up
you've you've you've grown up in the
United States a little bit are you from
another country
well um my parents are both from
Colombia
um they've met in the states uh I was
born and raised in Florida I grew up in
Apopka in Central Florida that's a
little bit uh Northwest of Orlando
um
I have a very uh interesting family
Dynamic I guess like you could say like
they're a unique
um things with the age gaps for example
my dad's quite older
um my mom wanted to marry him and he
just went with it kind of thing not your
typical
um
a background story for a family but
um I uh was raised in a low-income area
in Apopka
um I guess I had a lot of
um
like ghetto influence I don't know if
um maybe people could could see that in
some uh sides of me but like get me in
the right environment and my ghetto side
will come out
yeah yeah
um but yeah uh
okay now describe the the family
Dynamics because you said your your
father is is actually quite much older
than your mom just how how what's that
age Gap uh 32 years 32 years that is a
good age Gap yeah not everyone can can
say that for sure yeah yeah
my so do you have siblings
um yes so my father from a previous
marriage had two sons so I have two
older half brothers and then my mother
from a previous relationship at a
wedlock had my sister uh older
half-sister
um on my mom's side told her after
others on my dad's side
um but the closest one in age to you is
how far of a distance and my sister
about 11 and a half years older okay so
there's quite a span of kids ages in the
in the house I mean some are grown up
and and left but you grew up 11 years is
enough for you to be almost like an only
child yeah it was basically like that
yeah I was basically an only child I'm
the only one from from both my parents
at the same time I don't have any full
siblings
um and over summer vacation uh we would
go visit my mom's side of the family in
Colombia and that's where I uh I would
spend time with my sister
um that's
um my my sister she was actually raised
by my mother's parents she was taken
away from my mother by her parents
um when she was when my sister was three
years old so they took the child away
because
um I uh like just just based on my
grandmother's judgments I mean I'm sure
she she didn't think that my mother
would be a fit mother for my sister so
she you know took her away and raised
her herself now your mom you were
sharing with me is kind of interesting
because you your name marionk
describe why your Mom married a couple
Concepts together for your name what is
that yeah yeah so
um she messed up the uh Egyptian elk
it's like the
um popular pop culture uh Egyptian
symbol with like it's like a cross with
a loop at the top quite popular it's
spelled a n k h she left the H off and
she messed it up with the name Mariana
so Mariana ankh Marriott
so your mom was into spiritualism a bit
a lot of spiritualism a lot of new age
uh tarot cards
um angels and aliens and uh crystals and
did she ever meet any of them and and
talk with the spirits or talk with the
angels do you know
um I've never really personally really
quite talked to her about that but she
would I would overhear a lot of uh phone
conversations that she'd have with her
other New Age friends and they would
talk a lot about that stuff I'm sure
yeah she had her own personal experience
with that in that so did you have any
kind of Christianity influence in the
house at all
so my father
um he was raised Roman Catholic just
like my my mother was
um it's uh like I'd say any Hispanic
country is very heavily steeped into
Roman Catholicism because of Spain
um as well as new age and
um
a lot of uh maybe you can have like some
witchcraft in there sometimes or you
know uh Superstition especially
um a lot of
little uh carrying over from Spain
um my father
uh he
um
didn't really
like settle well with like the whole
doctrines of Roman Catholicism though
um and when he moved to the states he
lived for some time in California and
um and there he met an Adventist couple
who showed him in biblical truth and and
he converted to um adventism and raised
being Adventist beautiful yeah so you
were starting to get some of these
influences but there was still some
troubling things that were happening in
your home what was going on between your
mom and you and and uh you know your
home situation at this point
so my mother uh was raised by my
grandparents uh in a very broken home
um
my
uh grandmother
um was very
um spiritually emotionally physically
abusive
um to all of her daughters including my
mother
into her firstborn son he was The Golden
Child he could do no wrong in her eyes
there's usually one that they'll
gravitate to and the rest of them get
the get the short end of the stick
yeah and so my mother did go through a
lot growing up
but she never resolved it and she never
healed and as far as I can observe with
with
um her you know having no peace no
Temperance
um
and developing an abusive
demeanor herself
um I don't think she she had a genuine
relationship with God you know I still
pray for her I I wish she she would and
she'd find healing and peace in Jesus
um but yeah she's physically mentally
emotionally and spiritually just
unstable and because she didn't resolve
um the different things she she grew up
with and traumas and things like that
um she passed it on to me even if she
didn't try
um she was very
um physically in some ways and
um spiritually definitely and
emotionally abusive to me and to my dad
yeah so how did you kind of get around
or out of that what was what was going
on did you have to leave the house or
you know was this getting worse and
worse and worse
um
um so when I was about
six six seven eight years old uh she had
to
leave for Columbia for a while to do a
lot of surgeries because she has like a
lot of health conditions
and so
um she went to Columbia and she's like
okay I'll be back next month and I would
be you know talking to her and I was
pretty close to her as when you know
when I was smaller
um it's like oh Mommy when are you
coming back and uh and then the next bus
became the next month and then next year
and then next few years and so it was
basically my dad being a single dad
raising me wow not knowing how to raise
a daughter right
um and so I uh
my my dad did the best he could but I I
felt very
uh neglected especially by my mother
um
and uh yeah I didn't have a good like
you know female role model to look up to
to teach me things
um my my dad would would be the the one
to discipline me and you know he did the
best he could to also be you know
nurturing nurturing one yeah
um and that's if if he could be you know
um present you know so like it's yeah um
but uh and so I I believe I perhaps uh
tried to look for family elsewhere
because I wasn't getting that at home
um and so I made friends friends with
neighbors friends at school
um then I would go over to their house
and spend a lot of time with them and I
think over the years I spent so much
time with my friends that I even
um
uh I felt like I got to know them better
and they were more of a family to me
than even my own family and that even my
own family knew me
um so it was like kind of like you know
you're looking through a window going
you know here's a family right here I
want to be a part of this family but you
you're still just the neighbor you know
yeah yeah yeah exactly wow and then
those friends ended up becoming being
toxic friends they started abusing you
they started abusing me oh no were they
male friends male neighbors male and
female male and female and
um
uh the the abuse started like since I
was six years old oh wow yeah
and continued on throughout you know
your your upbringing do you live in the
same house all the way through high
school and and
wow yeah
um so my my first set of toxic friends
was
uh a sister and a brother with a single
mom who their their dad was abusive and
she had left him and so once I found out
about that I figured perhaps that's
that's why they were also being you know
toxic to me but um I I was you know the
like I would come over to their house
and they would like demean me they
wouldn't even like let me sit on the
couch and treat me like a dog and have
me sick crisscross on the floor on the
rug
um watch whatever was on the TV whether
it was child appropriate or not you know
news or adult shows or whatever
um they would uh tell me what to do and
if I didn't do it quickly enough for
them or at the right time they would
physically harm me oh wow they would
always put me down verbally
uh like oh you're so annoying or oh shut
up like you know you don't have anything
valuable to say or whatever
um
and the the girl was four years older
than I was and the boy was three years
older than I was
um so at six he was like nine and she
was ten and then this progressed until I
was 10 and their mother uh ended up
remarrying and they ended up moving away
but
um they would even
I was six seven years old they would
even you know sit me down for the TV
um watch and then they would watch all
these horror movies and they would force
me to watch these horror movies with
them and to this day I still remember
yeah some movies and certain scenes
isn't that crazy like you know some some
kids are free to watch whatever they
want and some of these things are
downright scary I mean can give you
lifelong phobias of the dark or of you
know there's something out there that's
gonna get me or you know did you have
trouble sleeping after seeing some of
those oh yeah yeah I mean I've I've come
across people who's you know I started
seeing shadow people and you know had
really physical manifestations and they
had just opened themselves up to to you
know watching all these horrible horror
movies
wow yeah so where's your dad in all this
did you did you have an opportunity to
share with him or was this just like you
couldn't tell anybody what was really
going on
yeah so they would be like if you tell
your parents we're gonna beat you up you
know and they were already physically
abusing me and I didn't want it to get
worse and
I was
deathly afraid of of them beating me up
and I guess I didn't even develop uh a
strong trust relationship with my
parents
um because if I were to have done that
I'm sure it would have trusted that they
could protect me and so I would have
gone to them and said hey this is what's
going on I don't like this and then they
could have you know done something about
it and protected me but I in my mind
gave more power to my toxic friends than
I gave to my parents wow and therefore I
kept quiet and the abuse
um kept uh the the abuse kept moving
forward without my parents even knowing
about it oh wow and so did this kind of
Follow You into your high school days
and you know it seems that that people
that are abused seem to have a sign on
their head and attract abusers to
continue that down the road have you had
that kind of similar experience as well
yeah I would always be
um
uh bullied in in school from elementary
school to high school for being fat and
therefore ugly and incompetent at
everything and uh
I I had few you know true friends and
usually the some of the teachers would
would take pity on me and and help me
out and be friendly but
um
uh kids can be mean mean
no filter means no filter mean and it's
like you know what a what a hard time
already to grow up you know and you've
got all these different changes that are
happening and you know these different
social groups that you're trying to
figure out where you fit in and you know
if you if you don't quite fit in there
how does that make you feel going to
school every day
like I yeah I didn't belong like no
matter what I did
I couldn't find safety or belonging or
acceptance or love no matter what I did
um I think uh when you talk about you
know having a sign on your head like
um I think as I've looked into like the
the Dynamics of abuse and things like
that and the effects of it if you have a
the Survivor that has gone through it
but they haven't healed from their
victim state of mind
um
an abuser can easily uh pick up on that
like they can see oh here are signs of
lack of confidence fear
um sadness uh hyper vigilance of doing
something wrong because trauma
overwhelms the nervous system by the way
um and lack of boundaries I'd say would
be one of the biggest things the the
biggest one of the biggest things for
sure
um and so
um I think that uh and so throughout
School uh my closest friends are often
toxic and so
um I think that because of my uh
influence for my upbringing from my
mother being so toxic
uh emotionally physically
um spiritually abusive to me I had these
signs and not um you know to to everyone
else but I I never developed boundaries
I never learned how to do that my mother
had no boundaries
um and whatever she wanted she she
demanded it it was her way or or no way
she would go to Great Lengths to to get
whatever she would want there were no
boundaries it was very very very
unhealthy
um and so I think that's why I developed
those toxic friends that were neighbors
those toxic friends at school and I
didn't
um cut off all my toxic relationships
until later late into my teenage years
and I even had to get help from my
um non-toxic friends for that how did
you get away from all of this like what
was your turning point that that began
to heal these these really broken
relationships they were starting to
build
um
well I
couldn't find
much respite or reproof
um
you know my dad taught me about God he
would drag me to church with him every
week so how did your views of God you
know obviously God being a father and a
parent you know was this tainting way
the way you felt about God like if
you're up there and you're not helping
me what's your what are you doing are
you angry at God yeah yeah definitely
like
um it was very
um
the cold distant relationship with God
like
um like My Philosophy as a child growing
up when it came to God
was
um
that okay I can accept Jesus
um and his sacrifice for my sins and I
can go to heaven if I were to keep all
the Ten Commandments in My Own Strength
so I was essentially like a little
Pharisee trying to do everything in my
own strength and the only time I would
pray would be for
um for forgiveness of my sins if I were
to break one of those Ten Commandments
and so
morality you know like I did what was
right in my own eyes like I thought
that's in I was baptized at the age of
10 you know thinking that sin was doing
drugs and opening openly worshiping the
devil and breaking the Ten Commandments
that's literally all that I thought soon
was boy did I not know much of anything
at that point of course
um I think that it's great for children
to get baptized but I think that
um
if if they you know learn more and have
a
a groundbreaking experience where where
it's like a whole new layer of their
relationship with God that they never
had before
um Can solidify their decision that
they're making yeah you know you're in
such a different place when you're 12
years old than when you are when you're
18. and you know a lot of times people
that made that decision I was one of
those that made it at 12 years old I
mean I really was genuinely you know
wanting to follow God and then all of a
sudden 18 I'm you know out the door and
had to have no time for God and so um I
agree with you I think you know like uh
you know baptism is such an important
step to to really say I'm I'm all in
with you God and and I want you a part
of every facet of my life definitely and
I think that that's quite a beginning
with age and experience comes that
decision in more strength for sure for
sure but as a team later on I wanted to
get re-baptized because it's actually
accepting a relationship with Jesus so I
guess I'll get to that soon but um but
yeah definitely amen
um and so yeah I I ended up turning to
uh
a junk food for like you know comfort
food I ended up turning to
just you know spending a lot of time
alone watching a lot of TV a lot of
movies
um and then you know getting sucked into
video games
I was a severe addict uh wasted hours
and hours on those things yeah I
wouldn't sleep eat go to the bathroom
like I was just sucked in like I I
really wanted an escape from what was
going on in my life
um
and I you know I
whenever I considered God I had this
disconnect where okay Jesus saved me for
my sins but I have no savior from where
I'm at right now and so
um so where did that connect actually
begin to start to happen you you you
talked before we got involved in this
conversation that you know you you were
ready to end it
what part of your life were you in that
space I really wanted to end it was when
my mom finally decided to come back when
I was 15 almost 16.
um and then you know she her her abuse
just got more and more severe after that
um
uh appear from from high school uh
shared with me
um The Glenn [__] in the ABCs of prayer
and those sermons and so as I listened
to those sermons
I saw the character of God as loving
selfless parent and then
um because at that point I was so
depressed about everything and I was so
tired about keeping this
religion that just restrained me
I I decided to become an atheist wow
um and so then after you know giving the
shot of giving a
hit a chance uh in
in listening to those sermons and seeing
the character and love of God
um I felt Jesus speak to my heart and
offered to have a relationship with me
and I'm like okay now this is the the
real deal it's not about me trying to do
everything perfectly In My Own Strength
it's about a whole holistically
accepting
um Jesus into every part of that and so
I said yes and right when I said yes I
got
um all these insights from the holy
spirit in in like wisdom in in life and
like all the hard things I've been
through God has been sharing his wisdom
through the like as a fruit of of all of
of all of those hardships and and you
know sometimes I don't think that God
um puts us in those situations I don't
think he's orchestrating saying okay I
want Marianne to go through this awful
abuse situation so she she'll come out
on the other end but God can take an
awful situation and when you have that
Encounter With Jesus and you really do
meet him and you see this is what this
is about he actually does love me he
actually cares about me and that's all
you're seeking anyway that's why this
kind of a thing just breaks my heart
um
I want to talk to you guys for a second
about
you know why we do what we do at Little
Light Studios and
um the support that you guys share with
our ministry because you know it's it's
literally this type of a thing that we
we want to share with the world out
there there's so many people that need
an encounter with Jesus thank you guys
for patreon donors that keep our
ministry going to support this it takes
money to make these programs I know and
I've met so many people that have had
real world experiences and have had some
some Awakenings and some some lives
changed from the content that's come out
of this ministry so I just wanted to
thank you guys and if if you want please
consider supporting this ministry so we
can continue this work forward but um
I wanted to kind of
um hang on that a little bit when you
meet
Jesus
it's like everything else just begins to
make sense yes even the abuse that that
you you experience it's like you can
kind of understand we live in a broken
world
and and you you almost begin to look at
people like I I pity the person that
that doesn't have that realization of
Jesus in their life you know yeah and so
talk to me a little bit about that
moment that that you really did just you
know it was like a light bulb coming on
well um
I I think that uh
really like came over time when I you
know just
you know processed
um the things that I've gone through and
uh
thought thought about like others more
and they're suffering and it's like man
how did people make it without a
relationship with Jesus like and and
then you know I I uh go through that
myself more in in my um Journey but
um
I really wanted to uh
and my my life for the first time
um
at around that that time when when uh
Jesus offered to have a relationship
with me and I said yes I was really
depressed at the time
and and I'm like okay I won't end my
life because of my relationship with
Jesus
um and I was tempted to do you know
self-harm do all these other things
um and I think the physical abuse I
underwent
may have been uh the difficulty may have
been Amplified because my pain was
Amplified I have this condition
um the Cyber sensitivity to physical
pain I've had ever since I could
remember so I have early childhood
memories of
um at school we were like you know on
this
field trip at this jungle gym or
whatever and then there were you know
kids like climbing on this rope thing
and so I tried to climb on
and it hurt you know it hurt my hands
and I'm like ow and then like I had to
keep doing it because everyone else was
doing it I'm like oh this is torture and
then there was uh another girl
um and she in a more vulgar way uh said
something to the along the lines of what
were you talking about torture this is
fun that's like what and so I I realized
that that wasn't normal the amount of
pain I was feeling and so when I would
be you know punched have my hair pulled
scratched
um
even even just be physically abused for
the pleasure of my toxic friends
um
it's like that that hurt more than like
you know another child who would have a
normal sense of pain
um would perceive and you know still it
for for everyone going through that it
is terrible it is traumatizing
physically emotionally uh spiritually
when people say oh believe what I tell
you or you're going to be condemned
forever and then you know they twist
like your your spiritual World Views and
things like that
um and then they try to get a grip on
you that way so January is actually a
spiritual abuse awareness month I
recently learned that
um just like how September is suicide
awareness month as well
um yeah so anyway
um
I uh uh the the other type of abuse
is sexual abuse
and I think that that
um really ties into harming uh the
identity of the person
um and this first began with the
neighbors that you were living next door
to yeah yeah
and I'd say my mother did some some
things to me that I was pretty
uncomfortable with in in that realm when
I was a young child as well I I hope she
didn't mean it but yeah uh definitely
from
from the toxic neighbors
um sexually abused sexually assaulted
from different friends that I would
make and meet uh different family
friends that that we had a different uh
points of visiting like I was born in
Miami we would visit Miami ever so often
uh in Colombia there was a neighbor a
friend that I had but then his older
brother
um
you know sexually abused me
um and then just and it's so sad when
you know people
that that you trust especially if it's a
family member
um molests you you know sexually
assaults you you know like it really I
feel it really attacks on your identity
and so especially being sexually abused
by
boys and girls men and women
um who can you trust at this point who
can you choose it's everybody yeah and
then how your body responds to because
your body is built to respond and even
though you don't want to engage
um your body is forced to engage and so
there has to be healing done from that
but with the pain that comes from that
um
I I know that there there's been a lot
of rise in the um lgbtq plus community
and movements
um being
you know following their hearts
following their feelings feeling like
they need to be uh true to themselves
and live out how they feel on the inside
so did this begin to really play with
your head I mean obviously now identity
is a huge
um you know topic and you know you hear
these stories over and over and over
again and when you really sit these kids
down or people that are struggling with
that you talk about their past many of
them have a similar experience yeah over
80 percent of people who identify with
the lgbtq plus Community have been
sexually assaulted in their past
um often childhood and I'd say a hundred
percent of them have experienced trauma
because I've made good friends with a
few of them
and
um
maybe you know several of them and all
of them have been through traumatic
experiences the trauma and the
disconnect on the identity there is as I
see it you know they may not perceive it
as as that being a fruit of that
um but the way I see it is that there is
this inner Brokenness there is this
um you know no questioning of identity
you know what one of them one of the cue
letters is questioning in that acronym
right right
um in that uh group of letters there and
uh I myself started to
um
battle with with feelings of Attraction
towards women
and so I never
openly came out as bisexual I never
truly identified with with being
bisexual I mean I've I've thought about
it um but like I I recognize that there
must be
some kind of Brokenness in there because
um as I got to know Jesus more and I got
to see how
um Jesus designed things to be and
that's where we get our maximum long
lasting freedom and pleasure and like
like
a plant getting water for the first time
in a long time like this is what I Was
Made For You know so anything outside of
that is is something that the enemy
tries to throw at you to trap you and
separate you from him and then in the
end you just
um get stabbed in the back by that you
think you're heading to a good thing but
and and they're in just destruction
stumbling down right right yeah exactly
yeah it just breaks my heart you know to
think that a lot of kids
are subject to this unawares to the
parents you know I'm I'm just guessing
that your your dad had probably had no
clue no what you were dealing with and
um I mean this is this is a common story
that keeps happening again and again and
I'm a parent I have two kids and you
know we we my wife and I made the
decision early on you know our kids do
not spend the time in people's homes
that we don't know and and
um you know no overnight stays and
things like that we've done we've done
hopefully uh a decent job trying to
protect them and that's not always a 100
Fail-Safe plan either
um but yeah the devil knows that if he
can mess with your sexuality he can mess
with your spirituality those two things
are so oftenly interlinked together and
um so you know it really took an
encounter with Jesus for you to start to
unwind that yes and be like this is this
is this is what a real relationship
should look like yes because you've got
all these patterns of these broken
relationships and and and and you know
ultimately those things can impact the
way that you view God and so I'm I'm I'm
I'm very pleased to see that you have
had an encounter with Jesus and that you
you didn't quite you know just reject
him ultimately and you actually opened
your heart and gave him an opportunity
to to come into your heart amen so tell
me tell me a little bit about that when
you you decided to give Jesus a try
what happened after that
um
well yeah so uh yeah definitely with the
the nuggets of wisdom the the
realizations I would make you know
um and then so like I would I would
share them on Facebook and then I feel
like I'm just like sharing a a quote
from like uh a Greek philosopher or like
you know someone ancient and famous or
whatever like known for their
like wisdom and stuff
um but uh I
I always you know try to give the credit
and glory to God because that could not
have come from me on my own yeah
um and so I I started to
you know see see God's love more and
that you know that it wasn't his will
that all these terrible things had
happened to me and
um
but now that they have because you know
of freedom of choice he had to let some
things happen to me some things happen
to to people and I I understand
um you know asking God why
um or you know if if God is so good then
why why would he let such terrible
terrible things happen
um but the reality is is that we live in
a great controversy that's right and so
the more I looked into that great
controversy between Jesus Christ and
Satan the arch enemy
um
I I could see okay
we are on a trial and it's God's
character on trial
um God always gives us the freedom of
choice he allowed sin to happen he he is
just in his love and so there will be an
end to this but in the meantime sin has
to come to its full fruition and so okay
yeah it's pretty ugly
um but we've got to see it in its full
ugliness and so that's why it says in
the Bible sin will never rise a second
time because we've we've seen I don't
even know where that looks right that
road leads right there yeah yeah we
don't want that you know despite how
badly we were deceived we came too and
we're woken up in in the light of the
truth
um you know what what God shows us
um that that leads to death and and that
he wants what is best for us he knows us
the best he loves us the most and cares
about us the most and wants to help us
the most and is more than capable of
healing us and making a good
um
uh making good out of our lives and so
therefore he has the best plan for our
lives
and so
um yeah
um I
I uh but you know before before really
letting Jesus into my heart I would
share with my friends and other people
about God but I was trying to keep
everything in my own strength and if you
were my close friend and I cared about
you I would try to shove my religion
down your throat and I was wondering you
know why why my friends didn't want to
hang out with me
um so yeah those would be the ones that
wouldn't you know try to be toxic to me
so all my healthy friends I pushed away
by being toxic to them and I was
starting to be in toxic manipulative
even physically abusing them and then
when I saw that and myself I'm like yeah
I know I probably should not do that
it's it's it's we talked a little bit
about um generational curses yeah um
before and this is something that um you
had mentioned that there was multiple
generational things that had happened in
your family and you saw these patterns
talk a little bit about that
yeah so um
yeah there's you know addictions like
you know my mother
I enjoy drinking alcohol she she smoked
for a very long time she even smoked in
front of me so I unwingly you know got
secondhand smoking and I'm I'm suffering
you know physical consequences and
repercussions probably because of that
um currently dealing with peripheral
neuropathy in my feet and now starting
in my hands at the age of 24 like yeah
you're too young yeah yeah like usually
people in their 60s and 70s get that
yeah uh disease but but yeah I mean yeah
I'm pretty young but but yeah it goes to
show that anybody of any age can get any
disease but um but but yeah so
um
I think that when there are addictions
in a family and going through the
generations uh
there can become
um a tendency toward those certain
addictions
um
like uh you know with with genetics and
genes there's uh you've heard
epigenetics I'm sure yeah so certain
genes are to rewrite the yeah yeah
exactly you can rewrite the DNA by
turning certain genes on and off by uh
those genes are turned on and off by uh
certain environmental factors or certain
uh thinking um processes and things like
that uh so that's really neat that no
you can't control everything about your
genes but there is that part of the
genes the epigenetics where you do have
uh some some influence in that if you
want to change something about
um something you may have inherited that
you don't want like a certain tendency
to a certain addiction like uh for me
um I've become you know very intemperate
and you know over eating uh and
indulging and things like that because
my my mother and I took after her in
those areas and so I've I've worked on
on that and in Christ have been gaining
victory in that and been in recovery and
from that and you know other things like
I've gotten into a lot of addictions you
know mostly behavioral addictions uh
like you know video games as I've
mentioned before
um
friends in the past
um uh that toxic ones especially
introduced me to uh pornography and
self-abuse
um you know people call you know
self-abuse masturbation right
um which those have you know taken
people by storm you know a lot of
men for sure but I'd say a lot of women
struggle with that a lot of women these
days it's one of them yeah yeah it's you
know readily accessible and again it's
also something that
um attacks you in your sexuality and
therefore as well in your spirituality
and so
um
I uh
I'm also in you know in in recovery of
that three years in recovery First Alert
for that and demand victory over those
uh things for sure and um
yeah so it's
um so there's addictions and then it can
be you know generationally passed passed
on even just you know with the
epigenetics and there's also
um
for for domestic violence and abuse
it also gets passed on just like with
what happened with my mother she herself
was
um born and raised in a very you know
broken home
um her eldest brother my grandparents
oldest uh son the firstborn son
so like yeah sons are wonderful in in
Hispanic culture but the firstborn you
know wow yeah and so he was The Golden
Child for my grandmother in her eyes he
could do no wrong and so he would often
like do something but instead of getting
in trouble he would blame it on his
sisters
being one of them yeah yeah and and so
even if
they were innocent and they would you
know plead for their innocence
um my grandma would be like all white
why did you do this no you're lying and
then she would punish them um
and not just with corporate punishment
but like with straight up like hitting
you wherever on the body physical abuse
like my dad told me that in his days
growing up in Colombia if you were too
bad mouth you disrespect your parent
they would have every right to punch you
in the mouth and knock your teeth out
yeah wow every right to wow yeah and
it's like okay yeah wow yeah yeah
respect is is pretty huge
um for for us in Colombia we're we're
very intense all around so I feel like I
can be pretty intense and it's like oh
okay maybe it's a generational for me I
don't know but um yeah I can I can learn
to
to maybe
cultivate a positive side of that have
intense you know compassion and kindness
for people instead of you know
succumbing to intense negative emotions
that the anime tries to like you know
attack you're recognizing that there's
some abuses that are happening in your
in your life and that you don't want to
repeat those things right yeah and and
break the cycle yeah you're breaking the
cycle and and so once you've decided to
kind of like break that cycle and really
focus on your relationship with Jesus
what did that do for your moods and your
you know were you were you finding like
joy in life again
oral um I
I uh stuck a lot with my uh addictions
thinking that they were okay
um that they weren't harming me that
this is a harmless way to
de-stress from the
stresses of life
um
but I wasn't noticing at all how they
were affecting me in the long term or
harming me in the long term
um I didn't
it um like really
work on my relationship with Jesus
a whole lot like I would just like you
know have epiphanies and you know that
like you know go to church and things
would be nice
um have some nice you know Christian
songs to get through rough times but I
never really read the Bible for myself
um I've never read it cover to cover
before and I've met several people who
have and you know
um
not that you know doing good things in
your relationship will uh with God will
you know get you saved or make you
Holier or whatever it's it's for your
your own benefit it's you you do that
out of
um as a response as a fruit out of your
relationship with Jesus out of your love
for him because you want to spend time
with him as your friend
um as your best friend you know so
um I didn't have that like
frontal lobe engagement I think I was
too lulled in my addictions and in my
traumas and not healing from
the abuse I've been through to really
engage with with Jesus
um in that way and the frontal lobe is
where we connect with God right so no
wonder the enemy is using everything
everything is food
pharmaceutical industry you know
um abuse addictions everything to tell
all infernal lobes to try to get us
disconnected from God as much as
possible
um and to become
animalistic you know disease passions
these passions reacting off of the way
that you feel and that's I mean that's a
lot of programming that you know think
of kids growing up on TV and all the
cartoons and everything that's just like
ah if it feels good do it that's like
the ammo of Our Generations right
um so follow your heart do whatever
feels good to you and what's right for
you might not be right for someone else
I mean that's just kind of your truth
their truth it's like as though with
truth for relative yeah yeah yeah mercy
so was it a struggle at all you know
you're starting to get your relationship
kind of back on track with God what were
there some challenges in there that that
you were still struggling with
oh yeah definitely like I you know most
of my friends were worldly and and this
was you know me Me growing up as a teen
but like I um
uh as as time went on especially as I
was graduating high school the more
the stronger the grip my mother got on
on to me
um and you know I would fall for it you
know she would you know often guilt-trip
me and talk me out as you know moving
out because I wanted to to move out to
get away from the abuse but she wanted
to keep me there to have her control on
me
um
and so my
brother-in-law and my sister
um and her two daughters my two nieces
they uh
my my sister
came uh and stayed with us for for a bit
and met
um
who eventually became
um her husband my brother-in-law at the
time
oh and then he decided uh to move their
family to uh Oklahoma and so they
visited from Oklahoma
um I lived in Oklahoma City together at
the time and
um they saw my situation with my mom and
so they're like she can't fend for
herself as an adult like this
um and so they uh extended their hand to
me and offered to take me under their
wing
and I accepted I'm like oh praise the
Lord this is the way out
um and so with a good dose of adversity
um
I uh was actually able to go with them
and I left
everything behind
um friends family in Florida
and I moved to live with my sister and
my brother-in-law and my nieces in
Oklahoma City
um to kind of make a long story short
for the rest of this
um my brother-in-law at the time was no
better than my mother
um
so
every effort he put into developing our
relationship as brother-in-law and
sister-in-law
he was his 40s
um and so and I was in in my late teens
and so he made himself
a mentor figure you taught me good
things
but snuck in bad things in there
he would do everything he could to
manipulate me he would isolate me sleep
deprive me try to intoxicate me with
alcohol
um
and really
grew me and manipulate me and
um
just
gain my trust to where I saw him as my
best friend in person I even started to
see him as a father figure
but
he
um
abused me
spiritually emotionally he made me feel
you know slow weak and stupid and just
like he would really put me down
and sexually abused me
molest me over a period of time and this
was uh the period of six months before
he
um it's hard to acknowledge but my
spirit I want to describe it uh was
murder and it rapes me and and
it's like
I just
like
my
brother-in-law cheated
on my sister
with her own sister
without any consent you know like I
don't care if it's violent or using
coercion sex without consent equals rape
it is and so
um I
I you know I had
um
panic attack I I didn't know what to do
um I tried to like reach out to as many
people that I knew from Florida until
um
finally I I was able to get in contact
with
uh a mentor I had a lady Mentor who was
like the mother I never had uh who had
to move away when I was in high school
um and my best friend from high school
his cousin they worked together to find
someone uh for me to to go to and in the
meantime I was able to go to somewhere
else but my brother-in-law was a
frequent and welcome guest so he
manipulated them into turning against me
so I wasn't even trusted and I was
um is seen as as the enemy uh there in
in the place where I was supposed to
feel safe for refuge and so I tried
going to the YWCA and they're like well
if you're not in immediate danger we
can't take you in sorry it's like okay
well I mean my brother-in-law can can
come at any time in this place where
he's a frequent and welcome guest so I
was starting to fear from my life
because when I confronted him about the
things he did
he screamed at me what you did makes me
want to kill you
wow and
um later on I'm like oh what about that
whole killing me thing were you serious
about that yeah and so he's like oh
you're so immature you're worried about
yourself when you've ruined my life and
I'm like really
and then I bring it up again same answer
and it's like man like death threats
like I'm
I just I feel in danger all around I
feel like I have nowhere to go to so
finally I get
um
these uh this this phone number from an
Adventist Christian lady who runs a
program for women near the whereabouts
of Spokane Washington and I've never
heard of that place before I'm like okay
well I'm willing to go like I've gotta
go I've gotta get out of here I can get
killed like I don't I don't know what is
gonna happen next so I've got to go and
get refuge and so
um I had the phone interview with her
she accepted me I went
and about five and a half years ago I
moved to Spokane Washington and I
decided to embark on my healing journey
and get closer to God in that
um
and and then yeah the classes I was you
know taking you know I was able to to go
to core a few years later I I met a
church family and developed new friends
uh chosen family I'd like to call it and
so
um maybe we can we can talk about the
but but I did have a battle with wanting
to end my life after everything started
this again and no kid should be
experienced this I mean everybody when
they grow up they just want to be loved
they just want to give love and you know
grow up in a in a in a family
environment that you feel safe at and
hear even in your own family environment
was was not safe not at all and so it
almost seems like every place that you
turn has the potential to be a very
toxic environment and
um but you've made it through that
you're now you know out there in in
Spokane you got involved in this group
that helps
um on women that have been through
programs like that and you got a chance
to go to court core is a evangelism
school that really just trains lay
individuals to learn all of the Bible
basic Bible Concepts it's it's a really
cool program so that no matter what
field of influence you may go into in
life you have the tools to be able to
witness to people to help people
certainly yeah and so um you know I'm
sure your story is not done being
written so is there any Bible verses
that are very impactful to you at this
point that maybe somebody that's having
a similar experience maybe get get some
um inspiration from
yeah so definitely my life verse is uh
Jonah Chapter 2 Verse 6 which says to
the roots of the mountains I sank down
and the Earth beneath barred me in
forever but you Lord my God have pulled
my life up from the pit and so like you
know like just
experiencing sinking down to the
uttermost like I can't get out of this I
have no hope
but God himself
um pulled me out and is healing me
um and then next time uh for for suicide
and that topic
um I can continue with that portion of
my testimony amen bring the gospel into
it with my own struggle with it and with
my own research into it and and
everything like that is I know that many
many people are also struggling with
that too
um
how uh I I accepted and had like hope
for the first time that Jesus could heal
me because that was part of it I had no
hope because I felt like I couldn't heal
at all
um so yeah definitely uh Jonah two verse
six I would say that's my life verse I
think that is absolutely beautiful and
you know if you're struggling out there
um this might be uh uh an opportunity
for you to to just try and place your
eyes solely on Jesus
um you know
maybe something terrible has happened in
your life maybe maybe a situation that
was out of your control has happened but
know that Jesus is the Healer he's the
ultimate physician he can actually take
us and set us on the right path and and
to change that awful situation and to
actually begin to reinstill Joy into our
hearts and I thank you for being so
vulnerable I thank you for coming on and
and sharing with us your story
um leave a comment in the section below
if you guys uh want to discuss some of
the things that were talked about here
and if you want to look further into
um
some information or something is there a
website to this this ladies Ministry
that you're a part of in Washington
um not exactly
website but you you could look for the
the program
um if if you'd like
help
um with that and and see if if that
going through that program might be the
right fit for you it's called women's
healing and empowerment network uh
program when program wh and program
there's a Sherry Peters with celebrating
life and Recovery there's Jennifer Jill
schwarzer with the abide Network
intimate Clarity
um definitely great resources for
working through
um trauma and domestic violence and
um
yeah
um it's it's healing is is a lot of work
on our part
um it and it could take you know I I'd
say healing is the work of a lifetime
yes just like you know yeah
justification is the work of a moment
accepting Jesus sanctifications the work
of a lifetime Ivy sanctification in our
walk with Jesus as part of that healing
process healing us back into the image
of God well I think it's beautiful that
the Tree of Life with its 12 fruits that
come out in each season
um the Bible describes those leaves are
for the healing of the Nations and so I
know there's a lot of healing that
probably all of us need and
um the answer is Jesus and we hope that
you were blessed by Today's show thank
you guys so much for supporting this
ministry giving us the opportunity to to
put pieces of content out into the world
like this and hopefully will alleviate
some pressure from somebody somewhere
that is going through this very similar
experience
um so please like and share this content
if you know somebody that is is maybe
struggling with domestic abuse or or
um is suicidal or even depression and
would would love to see the show we'd
love it for you to share it with them
we'll see you guys next week amen see ya
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign